[Music]
good evening the Supreme Court said no
to the government and yes to the
newspaper voting six to three to let the
New York Times and The Washington Post
print the rest of the Pentagon Papers
that's anchor John Hart with the CBS
News report on the Supreme Court's 1971
decision affirming the right of the
press to publish the Pentagon Papers
their papers reveal that the US
government knew the war in Vietnam was
unwinnable years before it ended the
dramatic story is now being told in the
post the new film starring Meryl Streep
and Tom Hanks and directed by Steven
Spielberg but the movie never would have
been made without two inspiring women a
32 year-old first-time screenwriter and
a former studio head whose career at
Sony was nearly derailed by hackers I
sat down with them at Woodside press in
Brooklyn New York where part of the
movie was filmed this is a devastating
security breach that was leaked out of
the Pentagon the most highly classified
documents of the war the post covers an
immensely consequential week in June of
1971 when reporters for dueling
newspapers were racing to publish
government secrets that would alter
American history 10 hours till the
deadline so we dig in the story of how
the movie got made is a thriller in its
own right I thought that I was gonna
write this movie and and maybe would get
me an agent that was my expectation is
that maybe I would get an agent Liz
Hanna inspired by the memoir of former
Washington Post publisher Katharine
Graham wrote the screenplay in the
summer of 2016 but she never expected
the post to be made then her manager
leaked it to a handful of producers
including Amy Pascal I read this print
someone in my office got it gave it to
me said I think you're gonna really like
this I sat down and I read it and I
bought it and I loved it because it
beautifully encapsulated a story of a
woman finding her voice and our country
finding its voice at the same time
people are concerned about having a
woman in charge of the paper but she
doesn't have the resolve to make the
tough choices Thank You Arthur for your
frankness Graham played by Meryl Streep
faced enormous pressure from an all-male
Board of Directors to take the
Washington Post public just as the New
York Times published a blockbuster story
on the Pentagon Papers publishing any
more classified documents when a federal
court ordered the Times to stop
publishing additional stories at the
Supreme Court next week
it fell on Graham to decide whether to
allow the Washington Post and its editor
Ben Bradley to go forward with the story
do you have the papers not yet
oh gosh oh gosh because you know the
position that would put me in Graham
would risk prison time and losing the
family newspaper she inherited after her
husband's suicide she had to take a very
very big risk and she might have been
wrong you know the only couple I knew
that both Kennedy and LBJ wanted to
socialize with was you and your husband
and you own the damn paper there's
something that was really special about
this decision for her because it was
personal it wasn't just about losing her
company this was about telling the
people that she trusts the most in the
world that they were wrong
we are extremely gratified from the
point of view of the public and the
public's right to know which is what we
were concerned with it really wasn't
ourselves what do you think it is that
allowed this woman to find her voice
knowing the truth knowing the truth once
she knew the truth of what was happening
she could no longer protect people she
could no longer not say it that is the
thing about the truth it makes the
greater good
more important he's gonna go here Pascal
moved quickly on the production director
Steven Spielberg began shooting last May
and the movie was in theaters by the
year's end lightning fast by Hollywood
standards why was there that urgency why
do this all so quickly because it felt
like this movie needed to come out this
year mm-hmm it's just four million trees
did you have a conversation about that
did you and Steve we just all knew that
if we were going to do it the reason to
do it was now how much were you thinking
about a sort of political narrative of
today well writing this Amy bought it
ten days before the election so the
reality that we were living and then was
one that sort of existed before fake
news the situation that we then found
ourselves in that we've been in for the
last year I think has been a real real
weakening for the country where we have
to decide what the baseline is
of our morality and our ethics and what
the baseline of truth is the story of
the Fourth Estate and why Free Press is
important you know that we would have to
remind everybody about that again
Katharine Graham would go on to oversee
the posts legendary coverage of the
Watergate scandal and become the first
female CEO of a fortune 500 company her
story on film comes at a time when
Hollywood is grappling with urgent
questions about gender and power did you
see some of yourself in K Graham's story
I wish I could say that 1971 was really
different than 2017 but it's not as
different as I would have liked it to be
yeah and I think I have been in that
situation so many times when I ran a
company and everybody in the room worked
for me and they still weren't listening
to what I said one of the things that
makes the movie so resonant is where we
are now is a reflection of a culture of
people who don't speak up mm-hm and I
think that what it starts with someone
like Kay finding her voice and saying
what she wants and what she thinks
that's what's gonna change everything
the post was nominated for six Golden
Globes but it's the times up movement
that dominated the award ceremony it is
the best of times and there were some
times when it comes to gender and
Hollywood right does it feel like
something is happening is there a
renewed sense of purpose about what kind
of films are getting made or is it more
subtle than that I don't think that
we've seen like the kind of movies that
are getting made reflected yet I think
it's been - it's been felt for seconds
but I think it will you know you had two
women producing this movie you had a
woman writing this movie it's about a
woman on us - your voice
know your permission I think there will
be more movies with female protagonists
I think we'll see that what will happen
if we don't publish what are you going
to do mrs. Graham it is an incredibly
incredibly prescient to buy that movie
last year but with all the conversations
happening about gender and power the
press fake news government secrets I
mean it could not be coming out in a
more opportune time the fact that this
movie was made in less than a year is
astounding it's astounding is you know
anything about Hollywood it never
happens like that and Katharine Graham
was a giant